Not only would it be great
to see DeSantis humiliated in 2024 from
the perspective of the presidential race
and much of that is bigger than DeSantis
and it has to do with factors outside
his control
it would be delightful to see this
feeble attempt at becoming the
Republican nominee be so damaging to his
reputation into his political career
that it precludes him from a viable shot
in 2028 and what I mean by that is the
following if DeSantis becomes so
unpopular by virtue of the anti-woke
insanity battling Disney don't say gay
all of this different stuff
it may lead to a damaged DeSantis who
can't even plausibly justify a run in